Your Love Can often be seen as judgment
you wanting them to grow so much
because then then feel like that's not
possible and now they don't feel
connected to you anymore because every
conversation is just a push to do better
and they feel not good enough I'm not
saying that's what happens right now
with you and your friend but that
happens a lot where we end up pushing
the people we love most away because we
just see great things for them but they
feel judged they feel worse about
themselves now hanging around you
because you have expectations they feel
like they can't live up to and that
little tiny step is actually huge for
them it's just tiny in your world where
you're at now in life is not your fault
stuff happened to you okay but it's your
responsibility to fix it and where you
are right now doesn't have to be where
you end up instead of running away from
the industry because
you don't like it you go in and you
change the industry that's what leaders
do so how did you get out of dealing
with shame and comparison and guilt
how do you get done to believe in
himself because I know you you do that
that's like your core your message
but when they're just they're not seeing
them so forth of anything yeah it's a
great question I think something that
everybody can relate to because as we
all grow and learn and get better and
improve and read
we naturally just want to help the
people around us right you want to you
want to share it with people and then
we're frustrated when they don't they
don't pick it up
um a couple things come to mind first
off
a lot of times them just talking to you
is already a big step like don't judge
the size of their step you're capable of
taking bigger steps now because of how
much you've learned and grown
and we often get frustrated by the size
of somebody's steps like oh you're like
why are we still here
but what you're not recognizing is that
like they've taken a little tiny step
yeah and that little tiny step is
actually huge for them it's just tiny in
your world
so even them just
opening up and sharing that they don't
believe in themselves with you is
probably a huge step even some of the
conversations that they've had with you
about their journey in their life maybe
they've never shared it with other
people ever in their life but they've
shared it with you and I'm talking about
your your friends specifically but also
in general everybody when we try to help
the people around us just our
willingness to share is already a huge
step that we just discount we say okay
yeah and let's go
and do the sex but that's that's a giant
jump that like they can't even see that
as as possible and so we think that
they're not making any progress but
really in their world they actually have
and so it's just uh that compassion and
understanding for for where they're at
some people you need to crawl with some
people you can hold their hand and cross
the street and some people are are ready
to take big leaps and jumps like when I
did the Pablo at the beginning of this
session where I was kind of hard on him
like Pablo like you better go watch the
thing because we made that for you man
you know it's because he's already
achiever
and he can handle a bit of a push if
that was somebody who I didn't know I
would never go that hard on them because
that could shut them down they could see
that as judgment
Your Love Can often be seen as judgment
you wanting them to grow so much
because then them feel like that's not
possible and now they they don't feel
connected to you anymore because every
conversation is just a push to do better
and they feel not good enough I'm not
saying that's what happens right now
with you and your friend but that
happens a lot where we end up pushing
the people we love most away because we
just see great things for them but they
feel judged they feel worse about
themselves now hanging around you
because you have expectations they feel
like they can't live up to
right this is a big you know conundrum
so
step one is understanding that listening
alone is tremendous value just listening
to your to your friends listening to
them giving them a chance giving them
space to be themselves and to share
where they may not have been able to do
that ever before is tremendous value uh
the next thing I'm doing is
we went over this in my uh oh we haven't
actually gone up the damn we didn't do
this in Movie Makers right how to coach
the uncoachable we never did this no no
no everyone ever had a question coach of
all wow we did a two-part series just on
I've never done a two-part series of
movement makers but we did one on
coaching please do it and I said we I
said an option we guys didn't vote it up
there's an option to do a third of have
a coach D uncoachable that that just
never got voted to the tops anyway okay
well here's this is a bit of a preview
um
the next step is to allow them to
unburden themselves that people feel so
caught up in the weight of their life
that they can't make any progress
they're just carrying too much on them
and so they can't go forward because
they're weighed down by the past and all
the decisions that they made so they'd
rather not look at it at all
which leads to tremendous lack of belief
to your question you know at the top so
they need to be unburdened before they
can move forward so some of the language
that I use if you look at my home page
you'll see some language that does not
speak to Achievers like the first thing
it says at the top is it's not your
fault
right
of course it's my fault what where I'm
at is my fault right like that but
that's a cheaper talk to people who
aren't Achievers yet they need to be
told that it's not your fault uh and and
the difference how I I really fought
hard with that internally how do I do
this because I I would have a hard time
getting through to the non-achievers yet
it's not your fault but it's your
responsibility ultimately yeah right
like where where you're at now in life
is not your fault stuff happened to you
okay but it's it's your responsibility
to fix it and where you are right now
doesn't have to be where you end up so
some of the key things that you can do
instead of the push because the push is
not what somebody who is if they're on
borderline depression a push is not what
they need that's not going to help them
at all they need compassion they need
understanding they need a friend who's
going to listen to them
um they need support
they need you to lead by example what
you're basically doing is living your
life and Shining your light so bright
and you're looking for an opening this
is the key because they're going to have
a moment
of weakness in their own insecurity we
see like hmm I see what yair is doing I
see what Zayn's doing I see what
Andrew's doing
I see what you're doing like how do I
get that
you need them to come to you
you need to live your life not judge
them for their life you can't and I know
you're not judging them you're loving
them but it's interpreted as judgment
not judge them not give them advice you
need them to come to you
and say how do I do this
and it will happen if you keep loving
them supporting them and you keep living
your life and doing the things that
you're doing
there will be a moment when they come to
say a year how do I how do I I'm stuck
how do I do that and that's the moment
that you do something
that's the moment that you not just tell
them what to do but then you do
something together
you help them take the first step and
realize that it's not so scary
so I was like yeah how do I how do I
make a YouTube channel like let's do it
together right now
pull out your phone let's make a video
together not just give them advice on
like read these three books and go do
this thing like an action plan that
makes sense because then tomorrow
they're gonna wake up and it's gone
so whatever they want to do
while you have that permission to
actually do a little bit of a push
because they've asked
you do something in the moment
you make a phone call you go to the gym
you do the video like whatever the thing
is that they're struggling the most with
you do it in the moment
um and it's frustrating and requires a
lot of patience because we see them
hurting and you want to help them and
you know the world that exists out there
for them but it's a it's a it's a slow
long patient game
just like you used to be right like all
of us we weren't as growth minded as we
are today
you know
you've had the Good Fortune over the
past five years to learn the study to
read to watch videos to go to
conferences to be around awesome people
and you've learned a lot and you're a
lot more open-minded like how many
people are more open-minded today than
you were five years ago
right yeah I mean me too
so you're you're more willing to take
bigger steps
but earlier on you weren't and so it's
just having that patience
so that's a little preview that that's
uh that's a good that's a good starting
point I went maybe a little long on that
question but I like it it's I'm
passionate about it I don't know why
makers you haven't voted up that topic
come on now we'll make it happen at some
point but uh anyway I feel I feel for
you and I you know I felt the same thing
for the people around me as well
um and that's that's the short answer to
be able to do it powerful that's your
next book Evan maybe maybe how to coach
the uncoachable it's why I changed my
entire website around and just like last
quick little story like if you go to
Brandon burchard or Tony Robbins and
people who I love you know their
websites you see people dancing on stage
and jumping up and down and we love that
as Achievers but to the non-achievers
they look at that and think that's some
cult you just join some cult you're
crazy what are you doing there you're an
adult you don't jump up and down like
it's a seminar you're gonna bounce like
a rock star like what are you doing
you're crazy uh where I I don't wanna I
love talking to those people but I want
to talk to every I want to solve the
world's biggest problem I have to be
able to talk to everybody
and so the website if you look at it is
designed to be able to spread that
message right it's not your fault here's
everything I struggled with as well
but you're talking about YouTube channel
or what on my homepage just go to my
home page right another great line is
like you did everything you did the best
you could with what you had
yeah because as soon as you judge him he
said well you should have done this and
he should have done that and he should
have done that like I'll tell Pablo you
should have been there this morning
right you know and it's fine but I won't
I won't tell that to somebody
who I don't know or somebody who is
definitely on the outside because they
don't need more judgment they already
hate their own life they don't need
somebody else judging them and telling
them all the reasons why you know
they're not winning
um anyway that's a test that's that's
the taste that's a little taste I'm
deeply passionate about it I love I love
like I order your book already it's very
important I don't know if that's a book
we'll see we'll have to do a movement
maker session on it first then you gotta
make that happen
um
but I'm I'm deeply passionate about it
and uh I love taking on somebody's worst
like bring me your worst bring me bring
me the the worst non-believer in your
life
and let's go like those are my favorites
well we'll get them moving we'll get
them moving all right let's uh anyway
thank you for the question here and for
joining you know at this late hour
um let's move on but Linda has her hand
up what's up
yes I have a question about
um Outsourcing your video editing you
talk about
um that a lot can you give an example of
how you Outsource for somebody like me
like I can make the videos and but it
takes a lot longer to actually Outsource
so what would be your advice
so we'll go over super quick we did a
whole movement makers on it that I would
ask Yelena for the for the link back to
about system and tools all the tools I
use how we hire all the back end all
that stuff
um but basically I realize I suck as an
editor and I didn't want to get better
at it you know it's like I'm not
passionate about editing I did all the
first ones
uh not all of them but a bunch of them
myself my friend Mark helped me film a
couple of them
um but I hired a part-time editor
at the beginning I used upwork we still
use upwork most of our team is on upwork
we'll we'll post a job
that connects to the mission so
Christina's been my main video editor
for I don't know how many years now and
when I posted it I said I'm looking for
a video editor who believes in
entrepreneurs you know that was the
title
video editor who believes in
entrepreneurs and then the whole opening
was just all about the mission what
we're trying to do accomplish why I do
what I do Etc and my goal was to
to weed out the people who didn't think
that was cool and the weed in the people
who loved it right so some people look
at that and say well who's an
entrepreneurs that's stupid right like
I'm a video editor like great like don't
apply that we're not going to have
you're just not a good fit and other
people it's like that's amazing I can't
wait to I'm gonna work extra hard and
you know how little effort a lot of
people put into their resumes and
applications they see video editor and
boom apply apply apply meanwhile you
take five to ten minutes actually
looking at the resume they spent eight
seconds applying so you know you cut
some of that out and Belinda's HR
specialist for everybody watching so she
knows she knows this game very well
um
my editor Christina had uh believe
actually tattooed or does have to have a
tattooed on her arm
uh before we even not because of the
company like she had that
um before uh we even connected
um or she wanted to have relief tattoo
in her arm or forget which one but
anyways like when she wrote her first
email to me it's like I love this
message I love what you're doing I gave
her a trial job and she put in way more
work than than um I asked for I asked
her to do it in my style and she did it
in my style and then said I did it in
your style but your style kind of isn't
very good so I did it
like this
like that's so much better than what I
did that's great
uh and everything that you've been on
she's been on the team and then we hired
her husband Sam so both of them are
full-time and then we hired two other
video editors so we've got four
at least four editors now on the team
um
yeah so it's starting off
I love upwork you can use something else
um trial job see how you work together
leading with the mission uh you want
someone who believes the same thing you
believe but just has a different skill
set editing
and then normally uh I'll record my
videos off of this camera or off of my
phone depending on the day pop it in the
Dropbox that gets uploaded to her
she does all the stuff she needs to do
and then the team will take care of
everything else and the team right now I
mean we've got almost 40 people on the
team so it's it's a it's a
machine I guess now running everything
but my team basically has everything
ready for me in Evernote so I know what
videos I'm recording uh you know when
it's going out what the title thumbnail
ideas are I still have to record but
it's all set for me I don't have to
think about all of it and then after I
record everything else is taken care of
from the editing to the publishing the
thumbnail title my team takes care of
all of that it used to just be Christina
uh so I would record and then she would
edit upload title description thumbnail
Etc that was fine when when I wasn't
posting that much but now we're doing
20 to 30 videos a day
so it's you know it's just beyond one
person to to do
um yeah so that's the process follow-up
real quick question did you when you
first did it did you look at the videos
did you watch them after she first did
it or you just trusted that it was good
to go
no I watched I watched it especially if
we're trying even now we're always
testing new things
and so I'll watch those ones and I like
watching the videos too because I
learned from them you know like the top
10 videos are in my playlist still now
because I like them every day I don't
necessarily watch my parts back like any
special videos or mentally Evans or
whatever because hopefully I know what
I'm saying and you know but sometimes I
get inspired by myself too watch it if I
get oh that was pretty good yeah okay I
like that
um but yeah I think like anything else
you got you manage to process at the
beginning until it's set
um
and then I'll often come back in
I think like most entrepreneurs we come
up with the creative ideas so it works
for a little while and then they just
run with the same thing but then I'll
come in with the new like okay let's try
this this time let's try that and here's
a new idea I have and did me not hear
from me with new ideas for three months
and then I go on some crazy Spurs like
this is what we need to do now and then
we go and test it out so yeah at the
beginning I I looked at everything in
now you know much less so but I still
love a bunch of the content I still
watch a lot of it but the team it's not
now it's watching because I enjoy it
less
uh I'm checking for mistakes and I think
that's also part of just hiring for the
right Vibe I I hate micromanaging so if
you are making mistakes everywhere and
you need to be micromanaged it's not
going to be a good fit
right so if you're not getting the work
done on time or you need somebody
hovering over you just it's not a
that's not happening because I'm I suck
at micromanaging I love leading and
guiding and mentoring and all that but
not micromanaging so just depends on the
type of boss you want to be too
thank you real quick Monique what do you
got so this is my first one actually so
I'm kind of excited Monique welcome
aboard I just finished the book probably
about a week ago
um and I put a question in the um the
group because I figured out my how on my
what but I'm having a really hard time
connecting it to my hot I mean my what
my who but I can't really figure out a
how that I feel like is gonna be
something that I can do that's going to
be like
career-wise
well what did what did you what did you
struggle with and then how did you get
out of it so I've struggled with a lot
like I can't really nail it down like
I've had a lot of a lot of adversity in
my life and my words came up as belief
tenacity and authenticity and then my
other words were shame and comparison
and I've been in the network marketing
and the marketing and the sales space
for probably 20 years and that kind of
is in that culture right so
um I'm trying to figure out a way to
bridge my experiences to something that
I really want to wake up and do because
I'm no longer at all passionate about
what I'm doing I feel like it's just
something I'm doing I'm going through
the motions and I know that I meant to
use this I just can't figure out how
so how did you get out of dealing with
shame and comparison and guilt
I mean
a lot of self-development work
and a lot of retrospectrum and
self-realizations and a lot of taking
responsibility but I've always been kind
of a driven individual I'm one of those
people that like just like kind of the
get done girl so I have that personality
behind me and I have that little bit of
strength that like I I'm stubborn and I
don't know if that like you were talking
before that doesn't relate my
personality I feel like I have a hard
time relating because I'm I'm not
I'm not in that I've never really been
in the place where I've believed it's my
fault
I may have felt like that but I never
believed it if that makes sense
and listen you don't have to Target
everybody I want to solve the world's
biggest problem I have to go help
everybody it doesn't have to be for you
if you love helping stubborn people get
unstuck and move forward that could be
the thing that you do well I think when
I look at it and I boil it down and
something that's really been kind of and
I'm not really sure how to go about it
because I don't know how they work is
I'm I've always kind of been known like
you say being a beacon like a lot of
people will come to me because I'm very
transparent especially through Facebook
of my struggles my life I've been very
open because I know that someone may
read it and then not do something stupid
or have a better day and so
um I feel like this conversation isn't
being had enough with women but I'm not
quite sure how to bring that out and I I
don't know if a YouTube channel is
better or something like a podcast would
be better or how that relates to
actually having a career
I don't know that I want to go into
coaching let's put it that way I don't
think that that's my passion
that's fine you don't have to go into
coaching it's thinking about what so you
know your personal development Journey
helped you amazing there's a lot of
things that you tried that that didn't
work and a couple that did there's a lot
of books that you read that
were kind of a waste of time and a
couple that you pulled a few nuggets out
and a couple that were amazing and
worked really well for you there are
events that you went to that some work
and some didn't as we all go on our
journey there's things that we try a
whole bunch of things and most of them
don't have any kind of meaningful impact
but that's part of the Journey of trying
a bunch of things and especially if you
didn't have a guide or somebody helping
you to say hey Monique go do this thing
you could be that person for other
people
where the things that work for you
people who are like you will resonate
really well with it so you can shortcut
their path instead of it having to take
10 years to get there you can help
somebody get there in a couple months
where you want to apply it
could be anywhere
you could apply to network marketing you
can apply to women entrepreneurs you can
apply it to teachers you can apply to
anywhere you want what industry are
people
uh caring about guilt and shame and
comparison like every industry
so which one are you connected to the
most
you know which ones you love the most
okay you said you don't love network
marketing you know if you did that
that's the angle well it's funny is I
don't love that part of network
marketing and that's what it is like
that's what's Driven me away from it is
all of those things that come along with
that industry that I see
well then being the person who like be
the lighthouse in the Darkness
be the person that's what if you love
network marketing and you love the
products that you're selling and you
love the companies and and you would
recommend the products and services to
your mom because they are actually great
and you use them and the only problem is
that people are comparing themselves and
making each other feel guilty and living
in shame then be the change
and then you start attracting downlines
who are
in love with your mission
and then you train them and you help
them and you coach them
so if you love helping women and
coaching women it's like you're not
you're not necessarily being a coach but
you're a leader right and by helping
um those women who join you feel less
guilt feel less shame feel less
insecurity feel less comparison feel
less judgment towards themselves as well
as other people you're turning them into
better entrepreneurs inside your
organization but what you're really
doing is turning them better humans
based off of all the lessons and
struggles that you went through you're
now making that path a little bit easier
for other people
so this is it like instead of running
away from the industry because you don't
like how it did we lose her oh she's
done it uh you put your hand down and
like you switch somewhere else on the
screen that's funny instead of running
away from the industry because
you don't like it you go in and you
change the industry
that's that's what leaders do the
section in the in the book about be the
tree mm-hmm I don't know if that if you
remember that but that's that's it like
that's what you're trying to do
and then now imagine a world this is the
the Mary kayash story too
yeah that's I mean Mary kayash
powerful
looked over passed over
trained the guy underneath her who then
Becomes Her boss
is being told that you're just thinking
like a woman
you know and never gets promoted and so
she goes and she writes a guide for how
women can succeed in Corporate America
and instead of just releasing as a book
she says I'm gonna I'm just gonna go
build that company
I'm gonna create the company
that we can all succeed at together
which also happened to be network
marketing so it's a good it's a good you
know little fit so money can be the
modern day Mary kayash
but that's it is like you see an
injustice and she quit she left she was
at one business and then left to go to
the other business and then left and was
done with the industry not too far off
from where you're at like I'm done with
the industry because of how bad it is
and then she came back and said no no
I'm going to change the way that it's
done
and so it doesn't mean you have to go
start a whole new company but if there's
a company that you like or you have a
leadership team that you'd like and it's
just the industry is kind of Tainted and
you're tired of these people around you
like you you then build up a new version
of it and if you said hey I want to help
um ambitious
Kick-Ass women
build their own company underneath and
get mentorship and guidance to have more
confidence to stop living in shame
and to go I should build something you
can be proud of join my team
I'll help you that's a way better pitch
and value than
here's another network marketing company
and you know the typical training that
people get and and then it's on you to
actually be the leader right to be the
mentor most network marketing falls
apart because the leadership sucks your
upline sucks like if you have a crappy
upline you have you got no support
you're going to be the person who
actually gives support who trains where
people actually love to show up not just
because you're giving them sales tactics
or pushing them on their quota for this
month
but because you're helping build leaders
in the organization and so you're taking
all the things that you you struggled
with and felt yourself and now just
applying it to help these women grow
in inside a business not it doesn't mean
you have to go be a life coach but you
are a life coach you know inside the
thing that you love doing
okay cool
let's dive in so the question that you
guys voted on was by Oliver Gonzalez who
said how to deal with imposter syndrome
so imposter syndrome
there's two things that that um that
really helped me so I used to struggle a
lot with imposter syndrome and you know
hey still do but uh one I would look at
someone like Les Brown who I think is
the greatest speaker of all time young
Les Brown and I think that is
crazy like I can never be that good and
what's the point if you've been making
videos if someone like Les Brown exists
and uh one I learned to flip it as
inspiration to say hey that's what's
possible as opposed to I suck and I
can't do it that that this is possible
that somebody has done it so I can do it
too and I'm I was reminded of Les
Brown's speech about Roger Bannister
about the one minute uh one minute wow
four minute mile it's a four minute four
minute one minute mile be insane
that's the next record to break but less
has a famous speech about the four
minute mile that once once Bannister did
then everybody else started doing it
because they believed that they could do
it that they saw somebody do it so I
chose to shift my mindset away from well
look at what Les is doing and look at
what Tony's doing and I can't be good
enough to that's what's possible they
have more years of experience and I can
get to to to being like that
um if I work hard at it so that's one
it's like one look at the people who
have done it and using that as
inspiration as opposed to jealousy or
feeling less then
um and then the second thing is just
tying back to I'm helping the person who
I used to be right like all of you
you're helping the person you used to be
your purpose comes from your pain right
that's a thesis behind build to serve
you struggled with something you could
go back and help who you were five years
ago you could sit down on a park bench
and give that person some really good
advice
right and so instead of worrying about
what Tony Robbins would say or Les Brown
or whoever your you know your hero is
what Oprah might say to to that person
you're there
saying something and you could tell
former you something
and then there's millions of people who
are former you
and they need your help and so instead
of sometimes we're looking into a camera
it's why I love this format because I
can see your faces uh sometimes we're
just looking into a camera it doesn't
feel like you're doing anything
like is anybody watching does anybody
care you know it's hard to get the
energy when you just especially with us
being kind of extended at home uh now
just talking to a you know our phone or
video camera
um
instead of looking at a lens imagine
you're talking to you five years ago and
what would you say and you know that you
could help that person you may not feel
like you can help a stranger but you you
know you can help that person
and so just imagine that's you five
years ago so I'm 40 so I'm talking to
Evan I really still talk to 19 year old
Evan because that was when I was
struggling the most so I'll just imagine
19 year 11 and I'm sitting down talking
to him and that feels if you talk about
how to overcome imposter syndrome you
know you could help former you and
that's all you're really doing is if you
can picture former you sit there talk to
that person it feels authentic don't
worry about it having to reach a million
people out on YouTube or Instagram so
um those are the two things that really
help me the people that you feel like
you're an imposter compared to use them
as inspiration of what's possible and
then remember that the content you're
making is really just for former you and
and there's lots of people who who are
former you and they need your help they
need your voice they need you to step up
um so that's my quick take on imposter
syndrome I want to I want to open up the
floor uh see how I can help what I what
I love most is not just me talking but
making it interactive seeing what
questions you guys have what you're what
you're struggling with or what's on your
mind and how I might be able to be a
resource for you today so uh who wants
to go first you can put your hand up
like this or you can raise the hand in
the tool Belinda is already she's ready
to go all right well Linda I've been
waiting
I've been waiting to ask this question
so for a business or for what I do is is
time limited I mean it's employment so I
help people get jobs and once they get a
job then you know basically they're done
with me but how would you advertise a
market something like that to have a a
membership or a group
who so membership or group was
interesting
um it would have to focus on continual
development so what are you noticing on
Trends and employment in skills like
what are companies looking for how do
they level up to get to the next job
whether it's inside their own company or
to go to a different business in a
different role so that becomes more not
just finding a job but it becomes more
continual growth I don't know if you
want to get into that industry or not or
that's part of the business it's instead
of learning how to write so I know you
do resume skills right right they teach
you resume skills that helps them get
the job once they're in the job what's
the next level
of success for them do they need to
improve their communication skills do
they have to learn PowerPoint skills do
they have to learn sales skills those
could all be different training that you
provide or partner with somebody else on
to come in and be the expert at
um okay if you're going to do a
membership group
uh the other thing is just staying in
touch this is this is a lot like a real
estate agent you know they they they're
not in constant sales Cycles because
you're you buy a house every what five
years every seven years right so how do
you stay in touch they send out their
magnets and they send out their you know
their Trinkets and help you put their
calendar on their fridge
um what would be better is just to check
in every now and then see how they're
doing
you know like you've helped them through
something really important getting a job
when they really needed a job right
right it's not that they don't care
about you they just have moved on and
are thinking about other things
um so to get referrals like the business
becomes referrals how do you stay top of
mind with them so are you checking in
with them asking how they're doing
um are you following them on social and
you know interacting with what they're
posting
um what can you do to stay top of mind
so that they may not bring you back
or maybe another couple years because
they're happy in their job but they know
somebody who needs help so it becomes a
referral business
which one sounds more interesting or
both like it the referral Side by
staying in touch
and the membership side of giving them
ongoing education
okay
um well I mean both I could do both
either one I mean I can decide
yeah I'll be looking at I would look at
what is the number one skill that then
they need to learn
like if it was sales okay the number of
the number one skill that you think that
people need to learn that you've been
working through they need to learn sales
skills and communication skills you look
at Evan tinsman and you say hey Evan uh
I'm looking at doing a membership around
selling and communication skills do you
want to come in and and guest train
and Evan says yeah I'm down Robin says
no I don't want to do that and you go
find another sales or Communications
trainer so you don't have to be the
subject matter expert on all these
things you just find the people who can
do it and you're bringing the audience
thank you cool I'm excited the number
way to grow business is to sell more to
your current clients right so instead of
them leaving you you're part of their
ongoing career Journey
what else who's next Lynn is Lynn is
waving her hand and driving Lynn you're
making me nervous
I've I've got a few questions that I'm
just really anxious for you to help
guide me through well what's your most
important one and we'll dive in well
okay I'll come so I'm looking at the
road though if you don't mind
okay so I am a designer and artist a
decorator and my my message that I'm
trying to get out is that you can
reclaim your life through intentional
decorating okay and what it comes down
to is mindset and what you keep focused
on in your life you can bring into
fruition and it's not just I know that
you know what I'm talking about
um but it's having having those power
thoughts how to
um you know 2020 was a year that just
ripped people apart they felt helpless
they I've taken surveys that had
thousands of people respond through my
social and the words that this one word
that they use to describe it was just
unbelievable because the variety of
responses I could immediately sense you
know some people were on the negative
side and others were on the positive so
how do we get this how do you get the
message out about right right
so I want I want to empower people and I
just want to know your your advice for
what that platform to do that on is that
would you say that what I'm comfortable
on
um or
um I know you don't know anything about
me but
um oh no that's enough like so I would
if I'm you and and I'll just mute you
right now so you can focus on your
driving
um if I'm you I would Instagram is
definitely the place
and I I I'm living what you're preaching
right like this space was designed with
intention these pictures mean something
to me the colors on the wall like this
all me even the clothes that I wear I
don't know if you go that deep on your
thing but but in terms of just the
environment in the office I'm with you I
think what you need to do is not worry
about convincing somebody that they need
to do it but finding people and even if
you look here people have different
backgrounds and some of them might be
intentional and some of them might not
be intentionally look at Evan tinsman
and he's got
people behind him on the wall as well
even in our choice even going so far as
like your choice of your Zoom virtual
backgrounds to make that intentional for
how you show up right that could all be
part of it I would be looking at people
who are already in
the intentional mindset game who are
already posting about it on Instagram
because Instagram is very Visual and
what you do is very visual people who
are already posting about it just
haven't applied it to their actual
physical space
so instead of convincing somebody to say
oh man you really need to change this up
you really need to have an intentional
space and to say Lynn don't talk to me I
don't care about all this woo-woo stuff
this doesn't matter right don't worry
about trying to convince that person
instead you're taking people who are
already posting about it who are already
doing it they're just talking about it
in terms of their habits or their
routines or their clothing or the people
in their life that they're already of
the mindset they just haven't thought oh
this actually applies to my physical
space as well or they just don't know
how to do it because they don't think of
themselves as a creative or a interior
decorator designer so they don't have
the skill set so they haven't done it
but you want the people who are already
of the mindset and then giving them the
solution instead of trying to convince
somebody that this is important to them
so you're saying that
search for those
those Instagram I have a very small
presence on Instagram okay go through
build to serve
and do the fast passive Freedom you only
need your 10 posts on Instagram but it
should be visual you're in a visual
thing I need to be able to see it and if
you say if somebody said well Lynn I
want a really calm peaceful environment
that's not this right but you can you
can take them your job is to take what's
in their soul and throw it on the wall
yeah right absolutely but most people
have no idea how to do that because
they're not they wouldn't even know
where to start or or what to buy or what
color scheme or any of that stuff right
but you're taking people who already
know that they like that they just don't
know how to apply it to the room as
opposed to convincing somebody hey your
room sucks and is limiting your mindset
and belief system you should change it
yeah that's exactly what I needed my
friends thank you much love safe driving
Sean had his hand up what do you got
Sean I'm working my way through built to
serve okay and I figured out I believe
my who where my one word is consistency
but where I'm a little bit stuck is on
My Credo because looking at what you
have compared to what I came up with I
came up with Family Faith and field
representing well Family Faith and
career whatever but I wanted it to be an
F so I said field am I looking at this
the right way
uh it can be as long as it's I want to
have consistency in my family
consistency in my faith and consistency
and
the field and then it's it's equally for
you as well as your message
to the world
so you still your greatest growth is on
the other side of even more consistency
with your family people might look at
you and say but you're the most
consistent person we know with your
family yes but there's another level to
it as well you could be more consistent
with your family you could be more
consistent in your faith and even still
now more consistent in your career
okay your next level of unlock is still
on the other side of more consistency in
those things and then teaching other
people how they can do it too so
somebody comes here and says Sean I
don't know how to be consistent in my in
my in any of those areas I don't know
how to do it
you can give them the the template for
like what action steps they can do but
also the whole okay and inspiration that
it's possible
because people will feel like it's
I've quit on things so many times
someone like me I just can't be
consistent and you're going to share
your story how you didn't used to be
consistent and how you figured out how
to do it and it gives them the
inspiration more important than even the
steps is the hope that it's actually
possible
because they don't believe that they
could be consistent the number of people
who who message me and say I just can't
be consistent on anything
you could tell them what exactly what to
do but because they have the belief that
it can't be done they won't do it
right so that's where sharing your story
how you used to not be consistent
wherever you did struggle in any of
those areas in all of those areas you
you were not you were not as consistent
with your family as you are now
what changed what happened what did you
do right so in telling that story that
makes me feel who's inconsistent on
everything that is actually possible
then they'll listen to the advice it's
like okay well if Sean could do that
maybe I can too and that maybe opens the
door for learning
or if you just lead with the steps
they have the wrong belief system
they're not going to make any changes
got it okay good I'm on the right path
thank you so much I love it and then
like time in Lin's thing it's like well
what can we inject into your environment
to make it consistency like to remind
you like maybe now she's thinking oh you
need to have three pictures and one of
Faith one a family and one of your work
right or maybe the chair has to change I
don't know I mean she's probably already
going out with crazy ideas behind her
anyway but but that kind of thing
because a visual reminder of who you are
trying to be is really really really
important so
yeah Lynn honestly like having people
even read your one word or built to
serve uh to figure out what their who is
and their Credo gives a lot of insight
into the person so that you can design a
better space for them uh John's got his
see John's got a great example so John
has a virtual background because as he
put his hand up his hand disappeared
there it goes what do you got John
um
in the beginning of your career did you
have any challenges in doing videos
being an introvert and if so how did you
break through that I still do
you know like today this this is this
this is fun because we've done this
before and and I know it's all love but
when I you know this month interviewed
Matthew McConaughey and Deepak Chopra I
was still super nervous to get on and do
those interviews
um the way through is
a couple things one you do difficult
things like not allowing the fact that
it's difficult to be a a good enough
reason anymore the fact that I said it
was difficult means I have to do it
um two you focus on service that's not
about you it's about the message that
that you're not doing why are you doing
this because you have a big ego and you
want to be on stage no you're doing it
because you want to help you want to
serve there's people out there who need
to hear from you and they need you to
stop being afraid and they need you to
step up right I mean that's what I
literally tell myself before I'm about
to go on stage like these people need me
to stop being afraid and need me to step
up because what I've got could help them
so you shift the focus from you to to
serving and being of value
um
and I had a third point but I got caught
up in that second one
remember but it may come back
um if you if you could remember what
would it be yeah great thanks
um
uh oh I remember now I always focus on
who's here instead of who's not
so even looking inside this group right
I mean how many how many of us are here
20 uh we've had more we've had less but
I'm not saying oh why are there not a
hundred people here or a thousand people
here I'm just focused on Belinda and
Sean and John and Lynn and like the
people who are here asking questions and
and how can I bring value and help and
so again it's another shift towards
service where if you think about
you know you're making a video at the
the goal isn't for it to have a million
views the goal is for it to touch
somebody's life and if 80 people watch
it somebody in those 80 people maybe
that's a life-changing video for them
and so it doesn't mean that you stop
wanting to grow and build and get better
and push yourself and get more results
but the default mode becomes hey 80
people watch this
you know you guys showed up here today
hopefully I say something that touches
you in some way that allows you to go
create something at least that's what
I'm telling myself
to to get me here doing it right
um so that was my third Point yes I
remembered Evan you put your hand out
there you
know what you said because I I I was
hung up for a long time on and I'm not
as consistent as I should be but I'm
getting there getting back to it
but I used to be and we've talked about
this more concerned about views likes
and all that stuff but when I shifted
from what I thought they wanted to hear
versus just as you told me the the more
intimate stuff I get less views I get
less likes but I'm getting more people
reaching out to me individually through
messaging and email and things like that
which is ultimately what you know the
end game is anyways but I still struggle
with that because you're looking like oh
man
it had 27 views like you know and I
struggle with it but it's it's correct
it's just a reminder like how do you
it's just not fully ingrained yet
how do you get it fully ingrained is
that it's the it's the turning the the
conscious into the subconscious through
practicing so that becomes a default
mode
and it's not that you ever like just
fully stop caring about it yes you wanna
You Wanna Build and serve but reminding
yourself of what what is my ultimate
intention here of doing this that I want
people especially with the stuff that
you do is actually life saving
life-changing
um you know Evan Evan uh content a lot
about addiction and how to overcome it
and that's like life or death for some
people right more than what I do of
Entrepreneurship
um so if somebody messages you and says
hey this this
actually saved my life tonight I mean
that's worth way more than
five extra likes on your post it's just
a reminder it's like that you constantly
telling yourself that until it becomes
actually ingrained
you know where that that has crossed
into my world though of of sales the
type A the extroverts the particularly
like alcohol addiction runs really high
because
type A like close we we Chase dopamine
so it's amazing how many people are
actually reaching out to me that even I
know like peers of mine that I had no
idea same struggles but the outward
appearance is good the internal
struggles are still there but they just
mask it well So eventually it'll your
niche as well catch up to it you just
got to kind of let it take on its own
life and let it let it breathe a little
bit and that's where your story becomes
super powerful because they see you as a
successful salesperson who then also
suffered with this a lot of people just
aren't sharing because they feel
uh bad about their ego and their
reputation and they're supposed to have
it all figured out and be this type a
superstar salesperson Breadwinner for
their family achieve achieve achieve
meanwhile they're sitting at home trying
to drink their problems away and you
sharing that you went through that like
oh I'm not the only one
um is super super powerful
let me just end with a thought then I
was um
I was on I've been on podcasts I did my
brand lytics this morning and then been
on podcasts and interviews all day long
and then after this just more coming up
and
I was looking at my stats we've done
over 10 000 videos and and one of the
common questions I get asked that I've
been asked three times already today is
how do you deal with burnout
and
um I think it's a fair question I think
the key thing is that you actually love
the thing that you're doing
right I've made over 10 000 videos been
doing this since 2009. and it's been
seven years or something since I haven't
not uploaded a video
I'm here with you guys this this is fun
for me right like unless nobody shows up
or it's just you guys say hey Evan you
know it's kind of a waste of time okay
you know I'll move on to something else
but this is fun for me so it's not just
about the end result of how many views
or how many you know sales or whatever
like the end result's important but more
important is the actual process so I
don't burn out because it doesn't feel
like work when I when I look at my
Thursday calendar and I see you guys are
here it's like oh this is exciting I
wonder who's gonna show up I wonder how
like if if one of my answers here today
helps you take Bill to serve and do
something a little further with it and
then that has these Ripple effects out
like I can't touch the people that Sean
and Evan and Lynn and Belinda can touch
you guys are touching people that I I'm
not touching and so like if if this 25
minutes becomes one extra little push or
seed that makes me feel awesome so I do
it because I love the actual process of
it and I don't burn out because it's not
work and I think if you show up it's
like oh this feels like work or I hate
this so you see it on your calendar and
it gives you really negative energy
you're probably doing the wrong thing
but if you wake up and you love it and
not to say that compassion fatigue isn't
real and that burnout can't be real
um but I think you'll burn out a lot
faster doing work that you hate right
the example I was good is accounting I
hate accounting so if I was doing
accounting I would burn out in two days
but I'll make 11 years worth of videos
ten thousand times all day long like
let's go you have to pull me away from
this microphone
um anyway so it's just a good audit like
if you look at your calendar and you see
hey I'm excited for the day or do I hate
the day ahead and like what are the
things that are causing you negative
energy in the calendar today in the in
the week or the month ahead and not that
you can just shift it tomorrow but you
make your transition to say I'm going to
stop doing you just stop doing the work
that brings you super down which may
even include firing clients right one of
the business that I'm invested into
we're letting go of a couple clients who
pay super well but are just big energy
drains like hey it's not worth you
sucking your energy to help them go
focus on helping these people instead so
looking at your calendar and seeing if
that happens consistently whether it's
something that's dragging you down long
term that can't be a part of your plan
you have to find a way out and through
anyway that was a little fun little
ending rant I don't know if that was
helpful to you guys
so the question that you guys voted on
was for Corey Corey Reid who I see in
the house here who said how to come up
with ideas for for Unique high quality
content so
I've made over 10 000 videos
I've been making YouTube videos since
2009 and for me it's always a mix
between what do I what do I want to do
what what's what am I passionate about
with what is their domain for
and it's always at that intersection
that you're going to win I could love
the idea of doing a reader's group it's
like hey everybody who bought the book
why don't we do a Facebook group but why
don't we do a a call and invite people
and I could I could love that idea but
if nobody shows up it's not much of an
idea right and for other people there's
lots of options you could suggest this
to to say hey your readers would love
doing something like this but if the
author doesn't like it then there's no
point in doing it so it's always in that
combination of what do you love doing
with where is your demand because if you
love it but there's no interest there's
no demand you've got a hobby and the
hobby can be a fulfilling Hobby and
fills your soul to do it but it's not a
business and if you're only chasing
opportunity you're going to get burnt
out and not like it because you don't
enjoy the thing
every successful person I've studied
which has been
many many many over the years the number
one rule for Success they have is that
they love the thing they love the
process like I like being here with you
guys this this doesn't work for me I
don't see it on my calendar as a as a
stressor it's a yeah baby let's go talk
to the Insiders let's make it happen
um I'm pumped for it
so that combination right what you love
with where there's demand so inside of
that how do you get some ideas uh step
number one I would go look at
other people who are who are in your
industry so there's nobody who is doing
exactly what you want to do but there's
people who are kind of close to it
there's people who have done similar
things so if I'm looking at my industry
I might look to Tony Robbins or garyvee
or Grant Cardone or Brenda Bouchard or
any of those people who have content go
to their channels and two things one
look at what their most popular pieces
of content are
so look at their YouTube channel and see
sort by most popular and see what their
top videos are go to their Instagram and
see which ones although Instagram is
turning it off have you guys been seeing
that maybe it's a Canada thing you can't
see likes anymore on an Instagram so
that might be a little harder but you
can look at I think you can still still
see comments
um look at what post got the most
engagement you know on their accounts
right and and make your version of it so
if Brendan burchard's biggest video is
how to overcome your deepest fears great
you make your version of that
same title just make your version of it
so you can get inspiration from other
people's channels the other thing is
look at the comments
so look at
the YouTube comments the Instagram
comments from these other people you may
not have comments on your stuff yet
right I mean if you have comments on
your stuff then great tap into what
comments you're getting my first video I
had three comments in the first year and
it was my mom my older sister and then
some random person so I cherished every
comment but I wasn't getting a lot of
comments at the beginning so you make it
about
what they're leaving comments on other
people's channels you know garyvee is
not responding to everybody's comments
Tony Robbins is not responding to
everybody's comments
Mel Robbins is not responding to
everybody's comments and in there people
will ask questions they'll say Hey how
do I do this
great video Mel how do I do this she's
not responding to it you can be the
person who then responds to it
right so again it has to be there's
demand Fork because people are asking
the question do you actually want to
answer that question
right and in that combination is where
you're going to win so leveraging what
is already working for other people
doing your spin on it and then can I
authentically connect to this message or
not and in that combination you'll find
winning topics
um
you have to remember in this process of
creating content that there's only uh
there's not a million different topics a
lot of people feel like oh I'm going to
repeat myself I'm going to repeat myself
I said the same thing I already made a
video last week on that I'm saying the
same thing
listen I've made over 10 000 videos how
many videos I believe can you make
whatever you're stressing out about
about making the same video I've
probably dealt with it many many many
many many many times the key things to
remember are
one the person who uh has watched the
video this new one doesn't mean they've
seen the old one just because you've
made it before it doesn't mean that
they've seen it before
so for most of the people who are
watching my videos it's still new people
all the time
so you have to enjoy the teaching even
more than the subject matter right so
like think about the great teachers that
you had in school you had a great
teacher you may not have had a lot of
great teachers but there's one or two
teachers that really stand out in high
school University that you went through
why were they so great well they they
really loved the students
because they're teaching the same thing
like teaching grade eight math is the
same grade eight math every year for 20
years how do you not get sick of that
and want to go you know well because
it's not about the material they love
the teaching and it's new students all
the time
so that's what you have to think about
is you may have made the video before
but they haven't seen it so it's new
students coming in it's new people
getting exposed to your message
um
two just because they got it
before even if they did watch it a small
percentage of people might have watched
it before it doesn't mean that now they
get it and now they're all in like oh my
gosh I got it I don't want to ever see
this again right if you make a video
about how to have more confidence
great so now they watch that one video
and all of a sudden they have
Unstoppable confidence and never need to
hear the message again right like they
need your voice as a constant reminder
you represent something to them you
represent hope and possibility and they
don't have enough of that in their life
so they need you every day
to show up and create something
right
um and then the third thing that I find
really helps is I just try to always as
much as possible tell a relevant story
because I can get tired of telling the
same story over and over and over and
over again I could talk about when I was
19 and have my first business and all of
that stuff and I and I'm still happy to
tell those stories but I have I like the
challenge of trying to come up with
something in the past week that's
happened
so I film on Tuesdays that's my YouTube
filming day and
whenever I'm making content I'll I'll
always try to think up what's happened
in the past week where I've dealt with
this and sure I could talk about my tour
and how I broke my neck and Brendan
burchard stage and all of these things
but has anything happened in the past
week that's been around the same theme
and if I can do that then that's what
I'll I'll share and it's it's it's a
nice challenge for me and it's a
challenge for you as a as a speaker a
content creator or thought leader to try
to have something
new uh because those those themes keep
coming up so that's how you can make 10
000 videos around believe and just keep
going and make it more and make it more
and make it more
uh so that's my that's my hot take on
the subject how to come up with ideas
for Unique high quality content by core
read uh and now I want to turn over to
you guys how can I help what do we got
we got some time together let's make it
count lady Lexi all right come on in
I finally got to record videos again
25 minute video and I was like okay I'm
not going to edit it all that stuff uh
I'm going to see if later in the week I
can chop it up a little bit and
um and post it elsewhere on social media
but I was like okay I think I got the
structure but 25 minutes isn't that too
long no not if it's good listen I think
it's I don't know if it's good well uh
yeah
if it's a YouTube video your audience
retention Curve will tell you if it's
good right it's not my opinion or not if
it's good you see people watch or not
but
long is one of the top strategies I'm
giving to the names that you love and
know uh long form is the everybody's
thinking short YouTube shorts Instagram
reels short short short in thought
leadership it's the opposite long 25
minutes no problem hour three hours I
had a guy today in Brent Linux who uh
we're looking at his channel and I
challenged him
two weeks ago to make a three hour long
video where he's normally making four
minute videos five minute video seven
minute videos make a three hour version
of it it's like three hours nobody's
gonna watch that you're crazy it's like
dude you're here for a reason you're
here to listen to advice take the advice
or don't let's just do one and if it
sucks you could say Evan Carmichael made
me do it
and and he did it and uh it came out
just what eight days ago and it's
already doubled the watch time of his
average video
um suggested views which is the game
that you want to play on YouTube is
already his number one traffic Source
it's already double the revenue from a
typical video
um and it's gonna blow up I mean I was
shocked that it happened that fast
usually you're looking at for suggested
like 30 to 90 day window for him it
happened after eight days and it became
his number one traffic source so yeah
long is great if you are if you know
what you're doing if you're speaking
good content if you've got wisdom to
share
I would much rather you go along on in a
YouTube format than um then short but
good luck I love that you're posting
it's awesome keep it up
uh Niall what do you got awesome thank
you real quick uh with that because I
want to speak to that um do you know if
that video was edited or because again
editing down control can cut a video
down by a third a half even more you
know do you know if that uh that video
was edited just get an idea that the
long form if it's uh if it's going to
have those little elements in there
so his was a mashup so he took all of
his like four to seven minute videos and
squished them together into one video
uh editing is always going to be editing
will always help but it's not better
than not releasing a video
right so your goal should be to train
yourself as a thought leader as an
expert to be able to deliver a one-hour
keynote without needing a whole bunch of
editing because when you get on stage
you can't say oh just edit that out
you're here to do a one-hour speech you
gotta show up and be great and be fire
right so that's a better skill to teach
yourself than to teach yourself editing
so uh if you can edit it great but I
wouldn't let that be the reason why you
don't post like post get the video up
just take people deeper instead of
sharing your three tips give them your
20 tips
tell me more stories and if you can't go
that deep don't the the danger with
going long as you say the same thing 18
times because you don't know what else
to say so you're repeating yourself
about that don't do that that's not good
don't go long just for the sake of long
but if you can take me deeper give me
more advice treat it as a master class
that video especially long term will
perform much much better people are
going to learn like think about who you
used to be and how many questions you
had and what you struggled with that
that's the point of built a service you
your purpose comes from your pain you're
built to serve you got a message that
can matter that can make an impact
um
that person it used to be would watch
an hour video solving that problem and
there's lots of people who are out there
so
real quick on that one point I may ask
you um do you script not script we don't
script but do you have an outline and
then you go to just go to that even
while it's filming or while it's
recording you look down and then you
just edit out the time that you look
down and Screen I mean do you have a tip
when it comes to that because it's one
thing to go we talk from the hearts but
again on the point that you don't want
to repeat yourself
so uh you know to help keep you in line
what what tip do you have there so so
inside build to serve is the perfect
thought leadership template
with the skill set but what you could do
is there's a I created a like hacked
down mini version of it
that you can do in a couple minutes you
guys want to see it
I saw that with that Instagram it was
that uh that IG live that you did well I
demoed it on IG live but we can demo
demo it I'll show you now on the whole
line we're gonna make it fit on this
here this is the sticky pad and at the
top says believe so it's even cut down
your script should be here if you have
to script out your whole video you're
teaching yourself the wrong skills and
it's gonna take you way too long to make
a video okay so step one your powerful
opinion so now we're gonna make this
video together and hopefully everybody
learns in the process what's it what's
an opinion that you have what's a
powerful opinion Nile has that we want
to share
where you gain Success Through just even
one step at a time you you can what you
can get success one step at a time right
you can gain success at even just one
step at a time okay I'm gonna write it
down so that first sentence is what I
want you to memorize right and we don't
you don't have to memorize it here but
when you're making videos like that's
the thing to nail if you heard about
nailing something get into perfect get
the first sentence perfect because that
matters but if you mess up great like
study in it's the beginning it's your
first sentence it's not like you mess up
20 minutes in and you got to start from
the beginning okay so that already took
up I guess you can't see I'm like here
on the page so far okay next
we're gonna go to a story and all I'm
writing is story Dash
so what's a story I don't need the story
I just need a a bullet point like my
brother or my wife or high school
teacher or some story that you had that
you want to talk about getting
success one step at a time
what would the bullet point be
first job out of college great first job
now you could talk to that story for
five minutes for eight minutes for 10
minutes if you had to
right so you don't need to have that
whole thing scripted out it's just the
first sentence and you're going to jump
to the story and say hey when I got my
first job out of college and then it's
just a prompt it's a reminder
okay so now we're like almost halfway
down this page okay next
I'm just going to write three different
points and I want your three bits of
advice so how do I then do it how do I
then go get success one step at a time
what are three things that I need to do
just the bullet points uh being
resourceful okay be resourceful
persistence
don't be afraid to ask and don't be
afraid to ask
perfect you can't see the points but
like this is how much it's here that
much space left this is our script like
that's all we need
you can gain success one step at a time
your stories about your first job out of
college and your advice is going to be
resourceful be persistent don't be
afraid to ask this is
the
CEO
and it took us I don't know four minutes
to to come up with and and you did it on
the spot under the pressure with me
watching everybody else here too so
I appreciate it but but that's it like
that's that's your script so then all of
those points you could if you talk about
B resourceful be persistent each of
those are five minute stories if you
wanted them to be
so that's where we we get locked into
most people are either scripting the
whole thing because they feel like they
they're going to mess up and and they
can't get it or they script Nothing and
then they just blank out when the record
comes on like uh be resourceful
this is like panic attack right so
this is the good in between I mean
everybody's got a little sticky note pad
like this somewhere that's that's your
script and I want you to and if you
practice it you can get this done in one
minute instead of the four that it took
us but still a four minute to get a
script for a 20 minute video is a good
use of time and it gives you a lot more
confidence when you're stepping in front
of the camera
beautiful thank you so much all right uh
Robert what do we got well good to see
you uh the Joelle and spry and everybody
else on the call hello everybody I
wanted to ask you uh two quick questions
and uh and the previous two people that
were kind of a good segue to what I was
going to ask so what uh video software
are you using or what do you recommend
that's work well for you and also too
secondly what just can you give us a
name off some uh resources maybe where
you tap into some of your b-roll when
you're making your uh your videos
so video software I think we use Adobe
Premiere Pro I have no idea that's way
too complicated for me uh okay I started
using Windows Movie Maker
that was my that was my go-to back in
the day and then I learned a little bit
about Camtasia
uh and then that got complicated and and
my channel started making some money so
I hired a editor
um
I I don't really care too much about the
technology
especially inside of thought leadership
honestly I would I would
I mean I still make videos from my phone
I would just pull up my phone record if
I was starting over pull up my phone
walk down the street no editing post
next
because that's how you get better at the
scale like you're sitting there in your
car and I'll put it in the car phone out
just turn it horizontal and you start
recording yourself get the if you don't
get the first sentence down delete the
video do it again and that might take
you 10 times to get the first sentence
and then you'll probably get the first
sentence if you're like yes okay well
now you can't use that so you
you do it again
but that's where taking like 20 takes on
just to get the first sentence and then
and then and then go right and then post
that video and and I think if you want
to add music or whatever sure but like
the music's not going to save you if
your video If the message sucks so it's
you training you to do it so that's why
I don't care about the the editing
software at the beginning stages
um for b-roll you use
storyblocks storyblocks.com
it gives you
there's audio there's video and there's
there's images as well
um that's what my video editor likes to
use so we bought a subscription I don't
know what how much it is I think there's
different tiers and stuff but it's not
very expensive again though like no
b-roll is going to save you I wouldn't
worry about b-roll in the early days
because you're just going to spend too
many hours editing a video where you're
you're much better to just go make
another video you'll have a lot more
success making another video than
um
been worrying about editing and b-roll
inside thought leadership
cool salima what do we got
thank you
um I wanted to start by saying thank you
for putting this group together I really
appreciate all the work that you do so
thank you for that
appreciate it
thanks so my question was um if you're
starting uh is it better for the first
week to maybe start with three videos so
you create benchworthy
um
work or is it better registered with one
just just start put it up like I think
people overthink the start
like in the time that you spent thinking
about one or three videos you could have
already released five videos
okay right so just like get one up and
then do another one and do another one
and do another one another thing I just
launched three video channels YouTube
channels with Brendan burchard
and we just did the same thing okay
first video when you have your first you
give me one video okay we're gonna post
that one and whenever the next video is
up we're gonna post that one and and you
eventually find uh uh a routine and a
production schedule but at the beginning
um
you just see momentum
so just post like nobody's watching them
anyway yeah
right I mean at the beginning whether
you post one or three videos nobody's
watching anyway like you're talking
about binge-worthy content nobody's
binging on anything at the beginning
right so so let that be the permission
to just post okay okay and it's okay to
post a unedited video because that's
another thing that's kind of keeping me
from
producing videos and posting them
nothing should get in the way of you
producing videos
like getting them out a pressing publish
so is editing good yes but is editing
the reason why you don't post no
okay
right I I mean I have a team of editors
now we've got
four
editors five editors I don't know I'd
have to look
um so I mean mad respect for everything
that they do but if I was starting at
the beginning I I think I made a mistake
in the early days of my channel it's
partly why it took me so long to get the
took me five years to get the 7 000
subscribers partly because I was
spending too much time doing the editing
I just wasn't releasing enough content
okay
so just get it up okay thank you
good luck
what do we got I just have the the the
problem on I wanted to establish uh a
podcast on and with video channel
and it turned out I completely over
complicated and whenever I planned the
content I had a book with with all the
information I wanted to put in and then
I messed completely the protection app
because it was
two pages of of Story Each time and I
figured out when I spoke to to people it
was easy I have a flip chart here made
just just across with a couple of
information it worked fine but somehow
if I use it for the video I'm messing up
and and then again if I if I try to make
it to make it easy
um then I always have in the back of the
Mind hey that's that's two simple
content because what's what's driving me
is is relationship it's relationship and
business what what it means helping
startups I can help them getting Clarity
and and everything that are around
science but as soon as I start taking
videos completely messing up and and
that's why I completely failed with with
the activities and I'm just thinking
what shall I do
two quick things when you're looking for
a broad message it has to be simple
like if I'm talking about Advanced
YouTube strategies that video would suck
on YouTube and would just confuse most
people because like what is this guy
even talking about it's too crazy so
your social content has to be easy to
consume simple stuff
so step one and that's great because
that's why people hire you right for all
of you you could make money as a coach
as a speaker as an author as an expert
for the more advanced stuff so that your
your beginner stuff gets put up online
that becomes the lead generation for you
that builds the awareness for you and
then for people who want to go deeper
and the more advanced stuff then they
hire you right they get access to you
the second thing is uh one you're normal
I mean everybody would rather speak to a
human than be alone talking to a camera
in their you know office or room or
whatever right
um ultimately it's a skill that you want
to learn and develop like the ability to
be by yourself in a room and talk to a
camera as if it was a human is a skill
that will serve you for the rest of your
life
right in 40 years when we're talking
into VR cameras it's still there's still
always going to be something that's
recording you doing your thing and so
it's a it's a good skill to learn now
because it'll serve you forever
um the other part to it though is if you
find it easier to get started just book
a call with somebody
have somebody who's following you on
Instagram to be there on a zoom call
that you're going to give a presentation
to you say hey I'm doing a presentation
tomorrow about how to
XYZ like whatever you're good at who
wants to join in and then you have a
zoom zoom call like this right where
they go oh my God there's John looking
at me and there's joy and Leslie and
Sharon and Rick and Nicole like they're
all there looking at me so you're
actually talking to humans to make the
presentation it doesn't have to be as
interactive it can still be a
presentation that you're trying to get
for a video
but it's easier to go because you
actually see that there's a human on the
other side actually paying attention
okay thank you so if you want to get a
copy of Bill to serve and join us live
for our next training with me to ask
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love